remercier notre rapporteur pour la
rigueur qu'il a apporté à nous conduire
sur ce que certains ont appelé agissent
ce titre un chemin de crête je voudrais
aussi dire mon respect pour les
collègues qui ont déposé cette ppl et
puis je dirais sans mauvais jeu de mots
mais le mot m'est venue en écoutant les
derniers propos ne nous voilons pas la
face s'il vous plaît non mais
sincèrement et je dis moi aussi beaucoup
de sérieux
je ne voterait pas le texte qui nous est
proposé parce que et je vais dire avec
gravité
parce que je pense que les familles dont
nous parlons les mères de familles et
les enfants ont un lien ténu avec la
république
ses enfants sont scolarisés à l'école de
la république
là où on forge le creuset de la société
et que je crains que si nous portons
l'anathème sur ces familles nous les
jetions dans les bras de radicaux qui
vont dire que les français les rejette
donc je ne voterai pas ce texte je ne
voterai pas ce texte pour cette raison
et en même temps mes chers collègues à
gauche
je veux dire que je veux bien qu'on me
donne des leçons morales mais je
rappellerai que la loi sur les écoles
privées elle a été votée par cette
majorité sénatoriale
donc je la salue et en même temps je dis
à tous s'il vous plaît il existe dans
notre pays des lieux où la république
n'est pas c'est vrai à l'école et dans
l'école de la république quant à petit
enfant refuse de s'asseoir à côté d'une
petite fille cela existe aussi à
l'hôpital où certaines personnes ne
veulent pas être soignés par des femmes
médecins et cela existe aussi
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre à
l'université ou une pensée politiquement
correct interdire de tenir des débats
sur la prévention de la radicalisation
monsieur minute avait toute ma confiance
je sais le combat que vous menez pour la
laïcité à l'école et je vous salue rien
n'a été fait de cette nature auparavant
il faut le dire mais en même temps
monsieur le ministre la question
derrière la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui c'est celle du
communautarisme et il en va d'une
mobilisation de toute la société
du gouvernement partout mais aussi
monsieur le ministre et on l'a dit des
musulmans qui doivent aussi avoir une
parole sur le radicalisme et la
communauté et le communautarisme